it's crazy too because one of your more
underappreciated projects was the one
with Pharrell it's like kind of a cult
classic but that kind of ended up being
like the there's no call me if you get
lost if there's no Pharrell tape yeah
but it's but you know
to me or in my travels like the way
dedication and trap or die is to certain
people the Pharrell tape is to certain
people like I've had a lot of it's like
a cult classic it is and I've had a lot
of a lot of people from
a certain like you know like hipster
kids or just like
you know not not the
what you would think the normal gangster
girls listen or like come up and be like
yo that Pharrell tape changed my life
like the Pharrell gangster girls was
like it was this for me like so or an
artist too like that was definitely one
of those ones and obviously that was a
big inspiration for somebody like Tyler
growing up so yeah that was that was
that was a big that was a big tape for
me I mean because you know at the time
Pharrell was already like a god you know
what I'm saying of course so when I was
when he was on a skateboard P Vibes like
when when I got that phone call like
y'all I think I you know that I think
that's the only mixtape he's ever done
in his career you know what I'm saying
so for us for me to be a part of that
and when I got that call and then just
like you know just that's that's one of
those tapes that definitely is one of
the the greatest ever like you know the
way it's put together the Zone I was in
like and [__] was incredible
for you
how because I'm I'm assuming nowadays if
if a major label artist wants a gangster
grills one you have to [__] with the
music but two they have to have the back
they're not no one's getting against the
girls I'm assuming is that fair to say
oh you have to be cut in on the project
in some aspect yeah the way that the I
mean because like
things have changed
uh in the music business it's not the
same way it used to be no it's not the
same way so there's you know the the way
that we approach the business has
changed and elevated
um the the cost of the gangster grills
is not what it was in the mid 2000s but
you get a cut
um I get I get more you should get
something yeah there's more than just a
check involved right right for sure some
residual income there absolutely in the
in your Peak though what was the biggest
bag you ever got
to do a gangster grills because you had
some random ass Gangsta grills floating
around
yeah I did and it was obviously like
yeah this is I know what this one was I
think it probably was Pro to be honest
it probably came from an athlete it
probably was like a good like in in the
earlier days it was it was a maybe like
a 40 piece or something like 40K to the
gangster girls was it for like the
athletes rapper yeah was this which
athlete Carmelo Anthony
um Maury Stoudemire I did do one I did
it I actually did do one for Carmelo
sounds about right that it wasn't that
one but I've done some I've done some
very notable uh remember KD had his
thing going yeah we never did again by
that point I don't Katie never came to
me for against the grills
um
yeah I've done you know Jason Terry
DeSean Jackson Jason Asante Samuels uh
uh meta shot the meadow World Peace
Ron Artest has a gangster girls where
he's actually rapping on there of course
of course he does yeah
Steven Steven Jackson yep
yeah and uh we got some there's some
more out there too you were running it
up
I know had one early from you like from
Phoenix and I know he paid for it but
V's like my dog so I remember like I
hosted his next tape and he's like yeah
I got a whole project with DJ drum I'm
like
Dj drama no Judo
but that was probably what was that like
2013 12. okay